Andrew Tate security guard speaking out
Andrew takes main security guard has
spoken out this guy would have seen it
all and says Angie takes head of
security said that the ex-kickboxer is a
little bit paranoid but only ever asked
him to remove women from the home not
stop them from leaving like against him
he says the security quality worked but
taking his brother for several years
claims he was not once asked to prevent
women from leaving the Romanian property
the former special it's so funny because
like it's not hard to find a girl to do
this only fan [__] like if you get
there's so many girls that already do
only fans you know it's not that hard to
pick a couple of them be like yeah come
work for me I'll make you a bunch of
money and you get to live with me and
with this whole lifestyle like if a girl
wants to leave all right we'll get
another one like this isn't crazy it's
hard to I to make it seem like he had to
like hold these girls hostage which is
just the opposite right he's kicking
he's kicking kicking These Hoes out he's
too many hoes like I want to be inside
they're staying too late they're
overseeing they're welcome like come on
they're getting loud get of these broads
I get that but and I'm sure that that's
I I am sure that that's true no doubt
because I have had to be we have all in
our lives as people who at parties had
to be the bouncer sometimes he was like
you that happened to us on New Year's
last year there was like some younger
kids that showed up to the party so me
and my friends like told them to leave
and then they called the cops and we had
to hide for New Year's the ball drop
here we've all had to kick out kick
[__] out of the out of a party
that's fine but you know to be fair this
guy's uh livelihood is attached to Tate
so you know he has a he has a vested
interest in speaking in favor of Tate so
while his testimony may be totally
credible it could be easily uh biased
discredited because of his you know yeah
but it's the same thing with the girl
speaking negatively of him like oh I'm
getting offered to speak bad about him
he broke up with me yeah I'll speak I'll
talk [__] about him whatever it's the
same thing they have a bias against him
because he did something they have a
bias because they saw the good side I I
you know what I'm bad for what I'm about
to say because but I don't fully trust
these girls because their judgment was
so bad to begin with to become sex cam
workers and you know they're so lost
that I don't fully trust them I can't
believe there's not more girls talking
[__] about him if anything if like stuff
really happened yeah you're right like
the girls that are going and showing
their titties on camera you think
there'd be more of them that would be
like coming out saying [__] so the fact
that there's only two apparently is
pretty impressive right and I feel like
that would be pretty they would be
pretty easily influenced by politicians
who had a or people of power who had a
stake in I mean in creating this story
around another thing is like we know
like Tate is so famous we know that
there's news people going to these
ex-girlfriends and offering them sums of
money to legit give them dirt on them
absolutely that happens so uh that
happens you talk tell come on tell the
story I'm not telling I'm not giving
details acquaintance of mine slept with
a very very high profile celebrity who
at the time was going through a divorce
and it just got caught up by the
tabloids because that person was
followed by the tap that celebrity was
followed by the tabloids and she my my
acquaintance ended up being like in the
news and everything and against her will
and she received phone call calls from
God I forget the name of the equivalent
to TMZ one of those yeah this is the
late not late 90s
uh whatever big celebrity tabloids and
she received calls from several of them
offering money for her to go on camera
or go on record telling what happened
that night and she said no she was like
absolutely not yeah and that's the
celebrity had of course called her and
you know she assumed that you know
attorneys were listening in on the line
of course and called her to ask her for
her discretion and she didn't even need
that call she was just like that she was
like yeah I'm not in this for money and
attention I just I want to be left alone
so there are probably some women who are
receiving those calls going are you
kidding me I'm not turning on him like
he was a perfect gentleman to me I'm not
pretending and that's that's selling
your soul that's selling I have personal
proof that this is real no I know it is
real so you're going to tell me that
they're not offering they pay multiple
seven figures to have a woman go out and
talk about him it depends on the guy it
depends on what Tate you kidding me
these these Elites that are paying God
knows how much to have him locked up
forces Soldier told the BBC that was in
fact the opposite and on occasions he
had been asked to physically remove
women from the house without force due
to them being too drunk or causing
problems when asked about the
accusations against Andrew Tay he said
some of the girls misunderstood the
reality and believed they would be his
next wife it's what he told the UK when
he realized the reality it's easy to
transform from a friend to an enemy and
make a statement please he suggested
dismissing the allegations against Tay
that had him busted last month they're
young and stupid he said when are
specifically of the accusers that makes
a lot of sense yes that makes so much
sense with that Dynamic that's going on
there it's like in a business where you
have two like middlemen or whatever like
middle employees and they both think
that they're getting that's that coo
position and then you only give it to
one of them the other one goes from
being you know loving you to like [__]
this guy I'm gonna go talk [__] about
him everywhere same exact thing and my
is it not yeah it is I agree and he said
I never doubt Andrew so yeah guys the
security guard that would have been
around Andrew Tate and these women a lot
is defending them as well send a lot of
these women must have thought he was
gonna wife them up and when he didn't
they turned spiteful which guys
honestly I'm so funny I think he had I
think that was Dom Perignon and I've had
Dom Perignon and I was really
unimpressed with it done oh oh the
bottle who's buying you this you're not
buying that [__] uh cousin Chris got us
a little runs and I just thought that
buklico or uh leflore was better good
it's good I'm not no offense and Chris
is going to call me and yell at me now
this is crazy I can't believe he's still
locked up gotta take a trip this is
crazy I mean with on the words of two
young women and zero physical evidence
two young women who stayed for months
and somebody in one we we talked about
this in another video and somebody put
in the comments you know Mom have you
ever heard of Stockholm syndrome and I'm
like yes I have this is not a case of
stock yeah he's got him in the basement
and he's keeping them there for months
and then they're secretly following
so this the the vice correct me if I'm
wrong I the way I remember the the one
woman in the vice documentary was she
said they went on four or five dates no
hanky-panky and then on like the fifth
or sixth date there was Hanky Panky but
it was repeat and and then she stayed
for six months I mean I I think that's
what I don't know if that's exactly what
she said the order but I mean if that's
what she said that would make no sense
but the very first time that they've
that they fooled around she said it was
Rippy yeah 100 the first time this is
not a Stockholm syndrome situation not
at all I just try to think with common
sense here too like for like yeah
totally the first time you guys do
anything he's gonna go go out and do all
the the crazy fetish step whatever this
is no we're not talking she
she's saying it was fetishy stuff she's
saying it was violent and it was right
it's just it's just like the very first
time you stick around for more
but I just don't buy it like I don't buy
it yep I don't buy it either that's like
going and saying Bill Gates just robbed
a McDonald's for its cash because this
dude has such unlimited access to women
like I think these people are such
incels they don't understand how easy it
is to get girls at that status to where
it's like why though
I've talked about this before I guess
thing like it's just common sense Winona
Ryder is is extremely wealthy and she
got arrested for shoplifting like you
just can't explain people do crazy [__]
that's just a dumb broad being a dumb
problem no people do crazy [__] so I I
give some Credence to to that argument
of yours but it is not a defense it
isn't and it is not a complete defense
because people are very surprising I'm
not saying he did it but I'm saying that
wouldn't be the thing that I fell back
on what does he need that for he's got
broads everywhere he doesn't need more
broads you know he doesn't need to take
them and lock them up do you understand
what I'm saying they're just saying
there's better points to prove them yeah
far better points to prove his innocence
like these broads are dumb asses what
are you going to do all right thank you
trusted thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz and
I'll see you later
[Music]